có thể giòn Mỹ được giác từ năm 2020.
Nga, chú khó và cán ước uống hộ về nền vừa là
cáu vụ Mỹ vì phạm là pháp của tế
Nếu đồ Mỹ không tầy của Washington chỉ kêu gọi tôn trọng lụ của tế
mà không trực tiếp chỉ chết hạnh động sự du vụ lực
Tổng thực ký hợp của cảnh báo
chuyến sức của Mỹ tạo giá hiện lệ Ui Hiem
Mỹ vẻ dẫn quyền từ vệnh theo điều năm mới mốt khiển trường liên hợp quốc
cho rằng ông Mà đồ Rồi Rồi Rồi Anh Ninh
tương nhiên nhiều chuyên gia lột của tế nhìn định
chuyến sịch không ở Mỹ quyền của Hồ Đồng Bỏ Áng
và phát hiện lời ra chất thật và không đóc ứng điều kẹt tự vệ
chứ một cuộc tận công trong
Dù vệ y vệ quyền phục quyết tại hồi đồng báo án
Washington có thể ngăn chặt mọi nối lực truyền chuyến phát nghiệp